Wazzup👅🤘. I'm hanging out in Corpus Christi, Texas with my two brothers. I'm Mark, and I'm Scott!
Beyond yonder is the Gulf of Mexico right off this side here.
Today we're going to try an experiment, and see if we can turn ocean water into chlorine gas let's jump right in.
So, we just went down to the store and picked up a couple of containers
We got one of these cereal containers and a couple bottles of Smart Water. The water in here is great
but we don't really need it so we got to find a way to
deplete these bottles because in reality I only bought these things for the bottles themselves.
Yeah! Now we all know that ocean water is very very salty and so the theory here is if we pump electricity into salt water,
It's going to divide the salt NaCL into two elements. Sodium and chlorine. So here's the basic idea for building a simple chlorine generator:
We're going to use our jug here with a couple of water bottles.
We're going to empty these out, flip them upside down, and drill a couple holes in the top so these rest in the container.
We're gonna stick our carb electrodes up inside the bottle and run
Electricity into them and with a little bit of luck our ocean water we split into two gases; Hydrogen and chlorine. Let's do this.
Let's Rock
Science all right so our first step is to gather up as much salt water as we can so do the honors right fill this
Container up we're going to take this back to the house and physically modify our container to accept our two water bottles and start pumping electricity!
(Singing)
Alright, so update guys. We have just about completed this system
We took a utility knife and cut a couple of holes in the top of our container just big enough that our water bottles will push down inside
We cracked open a six volt lantern battery and extracted these carbon rods, and then we took those carbon Rods
We shoved them down the necks of these water bottles
All that's left to do now is take some insulated copper cable wrap it around these carbon electrodes and hook it up to a car battery
Check it out guys. We've got our bottles prepped
We've got our carbon electrodes in the necks with the electrical wire connected the black wire we're going to connect to the negative and this
Will Produce hydrogen gas and our positive is going to produce chlorine is it going to work science will tell us?
Let's go, hook it up to a car battery
All right, this is the moment of truth guys
This is where we connect up the car battery to the system
And if we've done it properly that when I make this connection the container should start bubbling
There you go, we got a couple little bubbles
Nothing super exciting, but I'm getting something in there. That's really weird though
It's like not bubbling inside the container. It's bubbling on the outside container
Yeah
That's not good
quick update guys we found that these tips of the bottles were actually hindering the process because they weren't letting enough water flow so [we]
Just ripped them out completely rewrapped the carbon electrodes and just shove them back in the bottles, and it's actually working better
If you look really closely there you can see with the car running [there] actually is an increased production of hydrogen wow alright
We're just going to let that sit [for] about half an hour, and then come back to check on it
So we moved our [setup] over here to a rental vehicle and look the solutions turn blue
I'm thinking that might have something [to] do with our copper wires may be copper wasn't a very good choice
We check our levels here. You can see we do have a little bit more gas in there. That should be hydrogen
It's not very much, so this is a very slow process
Disappointingly there's really not much happening over here. We do have a little bit of gas, but not much all right so update guys
We're failing I haven't tried this experiment before at home with just the carbon electrodes and a work just fine
[I] think maybe the copper is messing up the solution very interesting have you seen the solution?
No, it turned blue take a sniff of that tell me how [it] smells
You can smell chlorine you can you can smell chlorine in the water?
Yeah, just in the interest of time I pulled this out
This is how much gas we've been able to collect this should be hydrogen. We can confirm that by lighting it off
Whoa yep, so that's what we got guys. We got hydrogen gas and blue [seawater] yay, whoo Jano guys
It's the next day
I've let this thing sit overnight, and you can see the solution has cleared up
And we've got a blue precipitate that settled down to the bottom now
I talked to my friend nurdrage and asked him if he could explain a little bit about what might be going on here and this
Is what he said in the electrolysis of saltwater copper electrodes actually get attacked to form Copper chloride?
And if we're using copper electrodes and eventually the ph of the solution will get so high [that] it'll start forming copper hydroxide which is
The blue precipitate that we saw in our solution
so it sounds like what I need to do now is go back to the drawing board rig up a very very simple system for
Using only the carbon electrodes for splitting salt water into hydrogen and chlorine gas [it] is going to work
But that's going to be experiment for another video according to nurdrage
We're not going to get much, but we should get something and there's a whole lot of salt water in the ocean
So we've got plenty of resources to tap into so our failed experiment isn't fruitless after all by running electricity through seawater
We've actually generated four really cool components
We've made hydrogen gas which is extremely flammable sodium hydroxide which can be use as a cleaning agent or for making soap?
We've made a solution of bleach which can be used for cleaning and purifying and some
[for] hydroxide that has a lot of uses as well [electronics] dyeing clothes and paper
It's used as a fire retardant for flame proofing materials printing photocopying
pyrotechnics and even as a wood preservative
[so] there's a lot of uses for copper hydroxide so guys we're gonna have to put this experiment on pause [for] today
We're going to figure it out and come [back] with a solution in another video
so
Until then thanks to my brother scott my brother mark for joining us for this
Experiment, and thanks to you for hanging out with us as well. We [looking] for the next video. Talk to you then
Random always happens guys and the Beard is happening
Hey guys, thanks for [watching] and remember. I'm giving away prizes now on every new video
[all] you have to do to qualify is
Subscribe to my channel ring the bell and select to be notified when my next videos get released the secret link to my giveaways will
Be pinned in the comments for the first 12 hours if you like what I'm doing show your support right now by giving this video
A big thumbs up and share with a friend. [I] love you back. I'll see you next time